So I swore to say,
uh.
The truth.
The whole truth.
So. Uh.
I won't tell you,
I'm glad to be here,
but it's still an experience.
We are convened at the request of 5 deputies of the National Front,
the National Rally.
Sorry,
and it was unprecedented to be called twice.
Our co-manager Élodie Bernard has already been on this same committee a few
weeks ago and among the 5 RN deputies who have asked what we do again today.
When we come back,
none of them were present during our first daily visit.
This is,
0 slippage,
0 sanction procedure,
0 fine,
0 formal notice of the arcome,
0 warning and no defamation procedure.
Daily - And the politicians,
the relationship has never been simple,
whether with the power or with the oppositions.
But even if these relations are strained,
freedom of expression is respected by all,
except by the Rassemblement National which is bitter.
I am sorry to remind you here for years that our
journalists are not allowed to attend the public meeting.
And Mr. Belver,
you indicated that TMC was a private award
channel and that you assume as such to do what you want?
Can you already tell us what you mean by doing what you want,
how far?
What a limit you are setting.
However,
I would like to remind you that these TNT
frequencies are given to you by the French,
they belong to the French and that indirectly,
you exclude 13,000,000 French people who have chosen
to vote Marine Le Pen in the presidential election,
who will vote uh.
Coming soon for Jordan Bardella in the election.
Uh, uh.
European.
I made his comments on a radio show.
It was south radio and it was March 21deux-mille-vingt-trois,
it's important.
Uh. The date,
I invited you to promote a documentary about marriage for all.
So nothing to do obviously with the subject of plurality.
Uh.
In the media,
do I regret what I said?
Uh. 1 year ago?
Uh,
the answer is no.
Why?
Actually, I'm sorry.
The only thing maybe is that I was to seriously
spare incomplete that day since I didn't have a doctor,
That was not the subject of the interview.
Maybe I should have said,
we do what we want as long as we respect the rules and the rules,
we repeat it from the beginning.
Uh. From this commission,
we respect them to the letter.
So yes, indeed,
we do not receive U. R.
N.
On the daily set.
Uh.
But obviously,
the U.R.
N Are present in all missions,
in all headings,
in all columns.
So yes,
the speaking time is different since it is 1 speaking time in magneto.
This is the first time I can speak again.
Uh.
In my chronicle,
1 time of speech pronounced on other media,
But the time Of speech of the elected RN is well.
Uh.
Is well present in everyday life and it respects
pluralism as defined by the arcome once again to the letter.
When we ask the RN deputies,
it's like this,
it's no no no,
we are not allowed to eat,
it's at your disposal.
Mr. President,
it is done,
it is bought through greys.
It's because we keep sending our
journalists into the field to cover all the RN events.
We do it all the time,
so we don't have you.
We didn't let go of the RN,
we didn't demonize the RN And contrary to what has been said,
we don't use the magnetos to make time to speak
by ironizing it or just making bad spirits about,
That's not true.
That's why earlier I wanted to give the last topics you were asked about.